In this lecture, we introduce
Markov chains, a general class
of random processes
with many applications
dealing with the evolution
of dynamical systems.
They have been used in
physics, chemistry, information
sciences, queuing theory,
internet applications,
statistics, finance, games,
music, genetics, baseball,
history, you name it.
So what make these processes
so powerful and practical?
Well, as opposed to the
Bernoulli and Poisson
processes, which are
memoryless in the sense
that the future does
not depend on the past,
Markov chains are
more elaborate as they
allow the representation
of situations where
the future depends on the
past and, to some extent,
could be predicted
from the past.
More precisely, we are
going to consider models
where the influence of
the past on the future
is summarized by the notion
of a state, which evolves
over time according to some
probability distribution.
That's the link between
the past and the future.
We will restrict ourselves
to discrete time Markov
chains in which
the state changes
at certain discrete time steps.
The state at time t
plus 1, which is here,
is a function of
the state at time t,
and there is some
noise, or randomness.
As another view, this is what
we will cover in this lecture.
We will first introduce
the basic concepts
using the example of a checkout
counter at the supermarket.
We will then abstract
from the example
and give some
general definitions.
Afterwards, we will look
at various questions,
such as predicting what could
happen in the future given
the current state
of our systems.
We will end this lecture
by giving some key
structural properties
of Markov processes.
So let us start.